surprisingly enough you know cnn ran an
important article
a few days ago actually one that focuses
on an aspect of the covid story
that's usually ignored the headline is
this in japan more people
died from suicide last month than from
kovid in
all of 2020 and women it says have been
most impacted it reads in part
quote in japan government statistics
show suicide claim more lives in october
than kova 19 has over the entire year to
date
the monthly number of japanese suicides
rose to 2150
in october according to japan's national
policy agency as of friday
japan's total coven 19 toll was 2087.
japan is one of the few major economies
to disclose timely suicide data
the most recent national data for the us
for example is from 2018 the japanese
data
could give another give other countries
insights into the impact of pandemic
measures on mental health
and which groups are the most vulnerable
quote we didn't even have a lockdown and
the impact of covet is very minimal
compared to other countries but still we
see this big increase in the number of
suicides
that is machika ueda an associate
professor at wasita university in tokyo
expert on suicides continuing that
suggests other countries might seem a
see a similar or even bigger increase in
the number of suicides in the future
now as the article notes we don't have
up-to-date suicide statistics for our
own country but there are indications
that the situation will prove to be just
as dire here
um if not more so we've seen glimpses at
least such as the report out of los
angeles back in april
that calls to the suicide hotline had
gone up by eight thousand
percent eight thousand percent meanwhile
men's health magazine reported earlier
this month
quote university of glasgow researchers
have found that rates of suicidal
thoughts among young adults
rose sharply during the first
coronavirus lockdown their study
published in the british journal
psychiatry
examined the effect kova 19 had on
different groups at the outset of the
original chronovirus lockdown
by surveying 3077 adults three times
from 31
from march 31st to may 11th they found
that the proportion of respondents
reporting that on at least one day in
the previous week they had wanted to end
their life
increased from eight point two percent
to nine point two percent and then to
nine point eight percent
over the three waves of the study these
rates were highest and young adults age
18 to 29
rising from 12.5 to 14.4 percent
now these are not small increases and
the problem goes
beyond you know suicidal thoughts npr
again a surprise
published a report this weekend on the
mental health crisis among children
specifically
brought on by the pandemic or that's how
they put it you know really it's
brought on by the government and the
media's response
to the pandemic that's my own
editorializing not what npr concluded
the article talks about the increasing
rates of depression
uh of anxiety among children also
loneliness feelings of isolation
this is to say nothing of the way that
children's educational development has
been stunted
though as i've said many times i think
public school often does more harm than
good
children are certainly not better off
just sitting at home on their computers
all day
but that's what's happened as our whole
society gave up
on educating children because we're
scared that the kids might get us
sick again not not because we're scared
that they get sick because we're scared
they might get us sick
and so we said never mind with education
never mind about that we don't need that
for a whole year
the powers that be by the way are
finally noticing
that they have destroyed our children
and are now pretending
that that wasn't their idea or their
doing here's dr fauchi just a couple of
days ago
with a surprisingly new take on school
closings listen
dr fauchi new york city public schools
shut down again earlier this month i
know
your default position is that you'd like
to see the sco
schools open but how do you make that
happen
and how would you advise the incoming
biden administration on getting
a sort of unified response
well you know martha that's a good
question we get asked it all the time
you know we say it not being facetiously
as a soundbite or anything but you know
close the bars and keep the schools open
is what we really say
obviously you don't have one size fits
all but as i said in the past
and as you accurately quoted me the
default position
should be to try as best as possible
within reason
to keep the children in school or to get
them back to school
yeah he makes it sound like he's always
said
that you should keep the bars closed and
open the schools he said that this is
what we say
that is not what he's always said that's
not what he said at all in fact until
just now
but even fauci's slow learner that he is
is starting to understand
that keeping children locked in their
homes for months on end
in response to an illness that for them
is no more dangerous than the flu
is madness not just madness it's evil
it's an
evil thing to do to kids only don't
expect fauci to take
any accountability or responsibility or
to admit his mistake
instead he'll pretend he didn't say what
he said in the past and has always said
what he never really said and it's not
just children being decimated
continuing the surprises of news media
outlets actually reporting news there
was a whole flurry over the last few
days of news media outlets actually
reporting news it's pretty incredible
nbc has on their website a short
documentary about how the lockdown
measures
are impacting the elderly speaking of
being isolated nobody has it worse than
the elderly in nursing homes
they've been forced to spend you know
what could be and often is their final
months on earth
locked in a building speaking to their
families through windows or not at all
and dying alone with no one there who
loves them
so here's a little bit of that
documentary listen i understand that the
current policies
are in place because they want to do
everything right now to protect our
seniors and our veterans
and loved ones of families in nursing
homes
but our elders are now dying
from failure to thrive they're giving up
they've been alone for seven months
families
need each other
i was devastated when they told us we
couldn't come in
or see him and my father didn't
understand it when we
explained it to him over the phone he
didn't understand what the virus meant
this is my father at 17 when he entered
the service
he lied about his age so that he could
get into the army
and this is my dad in korea
in the middle of the jungle during the
war
so we did zoom calls and then we
graduated to
window visits and seeing your parent
through a window like an animal in the
zoo
hi daddy trying to hear him
trying to see him through the screen
trying to advocate for him
was heartbreaking you know it's it is
heartbreaking it's tragic it's
infuriating
the elderly isolated dying alone
children locked in their homes replacing
education with computers suicides
depression business owners losing
everything
and however bad we think all this is
it's worse remember that
we won't know the full effect for many
years we can't know i mean what are the
long-term effects of locking kids in
their home
making them think strangers are diseased
zombies
punting their education down the road
like it doesn't matter
in what way will this generation of
children be shaped by this to what
extent what will that shape be
nobody knows no society has ever done
anything like this
and how many suicides will ultimately
happen as a result of the lockdowns
even after we get to 2020 data that's
not going to tell the whole story a
business owner
you know who loses everything overnight
may not take his own life the next
morning
could happen a year later could happen
two years later could happen 10 years
later
many thousands of people have been put
on a path
of despair and ruin this year but the
end of that path whatever it is and
wherever it is
may not come for several years yet so we
know it's bad
but we don't know the full extent of how
bad it is
for that matter what are the
psychological effects of people living
their lives
without ever seeing a stranger's face in
public
how does that influence our mental
health does anyone know
no because again nobody has ever done
this before
and that's why the flippancy of those
who advocate and push the lockdowns
really
enrages me the most they have not
attempted to seriously
weigh the pros and cons they have not
bothered to so much as
wonder about the long-term or short-term
negative effects
we're doing something no society has
ever done embracing consequences that no
society has ever
willingly embraced and we're supposed to
do this without even discussing it
without any sense of caution or
apprehension
except the lockdowns or you're a science
denier that's it
that's meant to be the end of the debate
most of all we're supposed to simply
accept the proposition that not only
will the lockdowns make people safe and
extend people's lives but that making
people safe and extending their lives
is the most important consideration and
all other considerations
should be subordinated to it we're
supposed to believe
unquestioningly that lockdowns will keep
the most people alive
that there is nothing that could ever be
more urgent
than keeping the most people alive
anything that must be sacrificed
literally anything to this end is worth
it
that's what we're supposed to believe
those are the two propositions that you
must believe
you're required to believe yet both are
highly dubious to say the least
it seems there is a considerable
likelihood that when all is said and
done
looking back on this 10 years from now
or 20 years from now
we'll be able to say with certainty that
many more people died
because of the lockdowns than would have
died without them
but whether that's the case or not the
second proposition
that physical safety is the highest good
is certainly incorrect
not just dubious it's wrong our country
is founded on the proposition
that some things are more important than
safety
any happy and well-adjusted life is
grounded in the same belief
for an elderly person with you know at
best let's say two or three years left
to live
what is better to live those two are to
live those
two or three years and be alone and
miserable the whole time
or to risk living less than two or three
but to be happy
and to be with those you love for a
child what's better to live in isolation
to avoid the minimal risk of a disease
that
rarely has any serious complications for
children or to live a normal child's
life and to get an education
and to be with friends and to be outside
playing and doing what kids do while
accepting the mild risks involved
the lockdown advocates and our overlords
in government have decided that these
questions are easily answered
and that the answer is to prioritize
safety above all
in all circumstances even if by
prioritizing safety
you ultimately make people less safe and
depressed and suicidal on top of it
they say it's anti-science the question
but it's not
it is anti-human to do what they are
doing
[Music]
and it's time for us to stop going along
with it
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt walsh show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on
all of our future content